dernière ligne droite crucial pour le
break site si pour le royaume uni
l'échec des négociations est le scénario
le plus probable ce n'est pas la
position de l'union européenne a pour
ses membres un accord est encore
possible avant la date butoir du 31
décembre les deux parties ont décidé de
multiplier les négociations aient les
précisions avec grégoire doucet londres
et bruxelles joue les prolongations
alors que les échanges sur le brésil
devait initialement prendre fin ce
dimanche soir le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson et la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen ont finalement
décidé de les poursuivre sans indiquer
pour autant de dates butoirs une
échéance toutefois le 31 décembre qui
sonnera le glas de la période de
transition
selon des diplomates européens les
négociations auraient fait quelques
progrès ce lundi mais des blocages
persisterait en particulier sur le sujet
de la pêche
ursula von der leyen évoque une dernière
ligne droite crucial
tout d'abord il ya du mouvement
c'est bien la période de transition se
termine nous parlons d'un nouveau départ
avec de vieux amis mais nous devons
également être clair à partir du 1er
janvier
et ce dans trois semaines le royaume uni
sera un pays tiers à l'union européenne
et nous avons déjà prévu un paquet
financier dans l'accord nous sommes dans
la dernière ligne droite mais elle est
cruciale
nous voulons des règles du jeu
équitables pas seulement dès le départ
mais aussi sur le long terme bat ressort
à hoffenheim boris johnson accepte donc
de proroger les discussions mais garde
un discours teinté de pessimisme
la commission est très déterminé à
poursuivre les négociations comme elles
ont été faites entre nous et la
commission et c'est très bien
je dois répéter qu'un le plus probable
maintenant c'est bien sûr que nous
devons nous préparer aux conditions de
l'om ces conditions de l'australie et
n'oubliez pas tout le monde
nous avons fait d'énormes préparatifs
pour cela nous n'avons pas fait tout ça
depuis quatre ans et demi pour rien
parmi les autre pierre d'achoppement
l'union européenne craint notamment une
concurrence déloyale de la part des
britanniques
faute d'accord ce serait alors les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce qui s'appliquerait